[Music]
I'm Dana Jacobson from CBS Saturday
morning welcome to the dish it's going
to get a little spicy in this episode as
we explore Mexican Cuisine from
gluten-free goodness in Texas to Savory
salsa in New York City but first we head
across the pond to experience the first
ever Mexican restaurant in England to
receive the coveted Michelin star here's
Jeff glor
when you first found out that you were
becoming the first Mexican restaurant
ever in England to have a Michelin star
what was your reaction well I was really
proud I was really proud Santiago
lastra's origin story doesn't begin the
way it does for many internationally
famous Michelin chefs I didn't really
have this beautiful story of like my
grandmother was rolling past a while
while I was underneath the table kind of
thing you were eating fast food yeah I
was eating yeah I was eating fast food
at the age of 15 lastra bought a box of
Ritz crackers at the supermarket and
made a crab dip recipe that was featured
on the box
he has never looked Back Lobster began
traveling the world to learn and cook
including time at high-end restaurants
in Spain Russia and Denmark
until he got an idea on the beach in
Mexico an hour and a half south of
Cancun coal means cabbage yeah why why
name it that so it means cabbage with a
c and what we want is to represent that
things that are on their value can be
special if you put them in the right
context like Mexican food and Mexican
culture and British ingredients at coal
all fresh ingredients must come from the
United Kingdom not Mexico meaning for
example no limes avocados or mangoes
dinner is either a six or nine course
tasting and most cooking is done in the
middle of the restaurants so chefs can
see every Diner and vice versa there's a
transparency on both sides they see who
they're cooking for and you see them
cooking exactly you also can see there's
no microwave you know we
try to make dishes that are not
100 spontaneous so it needs to have a
story he needs to have specific
ingredients he needs to have a specific
flavor a specific look as well like I
want the people to know that he's from
color our presentation began with
nikuatole a custard made with corn Masa
traditionally from the south of Mexico
luster has given it a British spin using
apple juice and lavage with a little bit
of chili almond milk and caviar from
Cornwall your dishes have this
the heat the spice to it yes yeah so we
work quite a lot on spice we don't use
for example pepper to dress things with
salt and pepper we only use salt and
then the pepper or like the dressing
are the chilies so the chilies will give
you heat but it also will give you
seasoning laughter showed us his take on
Ceviche called aguachile made with squid
and rhubarb so in the bottom is this
paste that is made with pumpkin seeds
and it's a type of seaweed called kelp
so then the idea of that what she leaves
that you have this liquid and then when
everything gets mixed together it
becomes like a cold soup it's incredible
I've never had anything even remotely
close to something like this me either
no like seriously that's the idea yeah
yeah yeah the signature dish at coal is
langoustine tacos roasted with garlic
and smoked chilies and served on a
Sourdough tortilla with sauerkraut and C
Buckthorn and the head is being
compressed with the juice of the berry
so maybe as you can squeeze it as a lime
I squeeze the head yeah so that's it
will be a piece of life you know and
also it has all the flavor of the
langostin you know I'm sold on this
version yeah they just uh
go for it
that's amazing so this is inspired in
this lobster tacos that you can have in
Ensenada in Baja California the Smoky
Char that you taste where does that come
from that is from the heads because we
grill them in the in the chimney our
next plate was a one of a kind tostada
instead of meat Lobster uses beets from
Oxfordshire salt baked and dressed with
fermented gooseberries and walnut oil
and underneath an Emulsion made with our
bowl chili and then the beetroot is not
spicy but then the Emulsion is really
spicy so but not too spicy yeah yeah
exactly so then that allows you to like
keep eating more which was a good thing
because we weren't quite done yet there
was still dessert first up a palette
cleanser of sorts Sorrel and jalapeno
sorbet with mezcal and a pinch of salt
inspired by lassara's childhood in
Mexico where all treats come with a kick
I remember when I just moved to Europe
it was so unusual for me to see candies
without chili it's like what are you
guys doing here like
how you guys get joy of your life when
you're kids
without chilies without spicy food yeah
in Mexico you're a child you're like
with your friends just like everyone is
just sweating
[Laughter]
dessert number two a flan with British
mascarpone and rye and finally manuelos
fried dough covered in ancho chili sugar
served with ton worth ice cream with
walnut oil and a gel made once again of
C Buckthorn the idea of the dessert was
to think about a cheese board a British
cheese board
and then the idea is that you can break
this like this
take one piece and then you take a
little bit of that a little bit of the
ice cream and spread it in the bunion
your version of a cheese yes exactly so
that will be the cracker and these will
be the cheese and sometimes you have
like jam with the cheese you know
and uh and if you close your eyes it
should remind you to eating like a
cheese board you know it does
right oh my gosh
totally does right yeah cheers yeah
Cheers Cheers
after the break we head out west to a
family-owned restaurant serving up tacos
and tradition this is the dish
[Music]
the meatla cafe opened its doors back in
1937 during the Great Depression since
then it served generations of customers
in California our La Lele Luciano
learned the history behind the iconic
restaurant which also had a helping hand
in the creation of Taco Bell
along Old Route 66 in San Bernardino
California sits one extraordinary family
kitchen I remember it almost as an
extension of my grandmother's kitchen or
my grandmother's house this is it right
here this is exactly how it's been done
here since 1937. Mike montagno is the
co-owner of midla Cafe opened by his
grandmother Lucia Rodriguez in 1937.
it's where I would see her most
frequently it was where I saw family
most frequently and to me it was not a
restaurant it was not a business it was
it was just part of what made my family
who they were
after immigrating from her native Mexico
in 1928 Rodriguez opened mitla Cafe to
quite literally feed her family and her
growing neighborhood it was like during
the Depression so she knew what it was
like to be hungry and she told my mother
the reason that she was opening up the
restaurant is because she didn't want
any of her family members to go hungry
patio King though is also one of her
grandkids and the general manager what
is this place like now who comes in here
it's like generational customers
Sons and Daughters of people they used
to come here we come like any every
other Sunday we come down after we get
our church what's the tradition with uh
having menudo on Sundays hangover
enter through these old doors in the
lines that divide us disappear almost as
fast as their famous chile relleno on a
hot plate state senators Congressman
everyone comes here a place to be seen
it's a place
and Montano says one particular customer
in the 1950s got more than just the
tacos to go
the legend as I know it um across the
street was a burger stand called Bell's
burgers and the owner Glenn Bell
saw that my grandparents had a line to
purchase tacos at the time I think they
were 25 cents each and he wanted to
understand this food item and why people
liked it so much and why it was so
popular my grandparents kind of
understood what he was doing and they
wanted to help him and so Glenn Bell
armed with Dona Lucia's beloved hard
shell taco recipe launched Taco Bell
what does the family say about that
everybody's been fairly philosophical I
don't want people to feel like they
weren't successful or that they were
taken advantage of or anything like that
the generosity rippled beyond the
Treasures of the kitchen Through The
Years meatless served as a gathering
spot for Community organizing even
earning its place in the history of the
fight for civil rights
one of the most important stories that I
know about was the meeting of different
Community organizations that helped to
desegregate public swimming pools in San
Bernardino there were days of the week
that Mexican kids kids of Mexican
descent could not swim in the local
swimming pools those meetings led to a
court case and decision which
desegregated all California parks and
pools a precursor for Brown versus Board
of bed that was the importance that they
placed on this this restaurant was that
it was not just a place to serve food
but it was a place for people to meet to
talk to share ideas and to move our
community forward what's going not here
this is it's our own Ranchero chili
verde sauce that we make here
despite meatless reputation for
generosity there is one thing they won't
share and this is the secret one that
goes on the tacos or any of our other
dishes the recipe for their taco sauce
our most secret recipe there are three
people right now who can make it
including myself and we try not to ride
in a car together
for everything else the door stays open
the tortillas are served fresh and the
welcome warm as ever it's always been
about having the same spirit that my
grandmother instilled in this place in
1937. we'll come to my home share a meal
and we'll see you next time
foreign
here to New York City home to the
renowned Mexican restaurant cosme our
Michelle Miller sat down with Chef's
Enrique Olvera and Daniella Soto Innis
to learn about their authentic cuisine
to understand Chef Danielle Soto Innes
so you want to put
this is the scallop down right you must
make the rounds in her kitchen
[Music]
a fast-paced production line creates a
formula that works when you have high
energy and when you have passion
[Applause]
moving to a beat That Feeds a myriad of
pallets and where are you from Venezuela
and you New Jersey and where are you
from California it all fits together for
this 29 year old Mexico City native who
believes that everyone in her domain has
the potential to run the show it's
amazing to see that they can have a
chance to run their own kitchen you see
the tortilla ladies I don't think you'd
go to any Kitchen in America and see
this many women in it they're badasses
they're amazing she said it not me sorry
that ability to see promise has come
full circle because world-renowned Chef
Enrique Olvera saw it in her what was it
about her that impressed you Daniela was
it's always been really high energy I
think she also knows how to belong to
the team but also command the team which
is the heart for chefs to understand
after a chance meeting in New York he
invited her to Apprentice with him in
Mexico City his signature restaurant
that was ranked the best in North
America a few years later he hand-picked
her to partner and run his first New
York Venture this restaurant cosme has
seen enormous success
is that part of the secret the diversity
happiness the the mixture of happiness
and hard work and fun lachikis is the
best dancer that you'll ever see playing
host is something both have taken to
whether throwing their customers a
five-year anniversary party or simply
seating President Obama and the first
lady in 2016 even if neither chefs were
there in person my niece was being born
so I rushed I took a play that day were
you here I was in Mexico luckily their
third partner restaurateur Santiago
Perez was I was called to the front of a
restaurant and they very polite they
asked me late would you have the private
dining room available and the guy gives
me the business card and it's Secret
Service did it click then it kind of it
wasn't immediate you know I wasn't
expecting it
what did they think they loved it and
that visit came before cosme was named
the best Eatery in the U.S on the
world's 50 best restaurants list for
their own unique take on their Hometown
Food we have razor clams but we caught
them to make a
what this Duo seems to have accomplished
mixing it up while keeping it true I
mean you're a classically trained chef
and yet you say most of what you apply
in that kitchen comes from your
grandmother's kitchen I think we all
cook from memory
you can't create something that you
don't cherish I think it's important for
us to as Cooks to understand who we are
that was trained in New York and when I
came back to Mexico I realized I didn't
know much about my own country and
little by little we got to know our own
Cuisines all the regional Cuisines of
Mexico and we literally fell in love and
true Mexican Cuisine is what fuels their
menu you see five similar things which
is the Agave corn beans pumpkin
Chiles and on and on but we wanted to
Showcase Mexican food in New York using
the same idea that we use in Mexico it's
like taking a bath consider this dish
sea bass with its scales fried like
chicharon ah it's so satisfying I love
this
dressed with moho salsa there is a lit
make it nice and green oh it's gorgeous
yes I don't usually like scales but oh
wait until you try this one
that sauce is everything oh she likes it
I do okay what else do we have here or
Arctic char in a turmeric ginger and sea
Buckthorn sauce and sea Buckthorn is so
good for your skin
oh my God
but this is so light it's so not what
people think of when they think of
Mexican when you come to eat at cosme if
you see we like to have things that are
vibrant and and fresh we want you to
come out of the restaurant feeling happy
and alive instead of overwhelmed and
Bloated yes
[Music]
now that the duel has conquered New York
Los Angeles is next the recipe for
Success they say is simple if you don't
enjoy it you can't persevere just find a
good Mentor that will Elevate you and
that will compliment you and you will
learn non-stop learning Non-Stop and
seeing the results is really nice
[Music]
up next we meet an Austin Texas Family
who embraced dietary restrictions and
turned the traditional like tortillas
and chips into grain-free favorites
traditional Mexican Cuisine often
includes foods with gluten but when
Veronica Garza learned eliminating
grains might alleviate some of the
symptoms of her autoimmune issues a new
grain-free brand was born former CBS
correspondent Maria Villarreal traveled
to Texas to learn more about the family
behind siete Foods
south of downtown Austin nudged in
between warehouses and hipster clothing
stores since one of the fastest growing
food and beverage companies in the
nation
siete is where family cookouts double as
brainstorming sessions for some of the
most Innovative grain-free products on
the market we didn't see a brand
speaking to us being a Mexican-American
family that was doing what Chobani did
in yogurt or what oatley's doing in
alternative milk we really do feel this
great responsibility to share the beauty
of the culture that we grew up living a
brand born out of necessity Veronica
Garza co-founded siete after struggling
with her health I deal with multiple
autoimmune issues one of those
conditions is lupus my older brother Rob
had suggested a different type of diet
that could possibly alleviate a lot of
the symptoms and inflammation my whole
family started eating this new way with
me we were basically following the paleo
diet and eliminating grains at that
point we were no longer able to eat a
lot of the the foods that we had grown
up eating
like tortillas health-wise the family
felt better but cutting out gluten made
them feel like they'd also lost
something bigger you know tortillas are
the the centerpiece of the table you go
to any restaurant and it's chips and
salsa guacamole all of these foods that
add to the beautiful Mexican culture
they weren't on the menu for us anymore
you know we sort of felt like
sort of like turning our backs on our
culture not being able to participate in
this important
part and then it was around that time
that we're at Academy and my sister
shows up
with almond flour tortillas Veronica
quietly began experimenting with new
ingredients and found customers for her
product near the family home in Laredo
Texas I had a full-time teaching job and
on weekends my mom would get in the
kitchen with me and we would just hand
press like a ton of tortillas siete is
named for the seven members of the Garza
family that started the business more
than a decade ago by 2014 Veronica's
side hustle had grown and her younger
brother Miguel saw the potential so I
started to realize like oh man you know
this product
could actually be sold in stores and if
people are buying it
on the weekends from you they might buy
it at a couple of like natural food
stores the company offers 40 gluten-free
Hispanic inspired products selling in
more than 15
000 stores nationwide I'm really really
proud it's hard for me to even talk
about it because I cry all the time when
I see our tortillas in stores it still
makes me cry for the Garza family
business the payoff is discovering the
impact they have on families like theirs
this you've changed my life with this
tortilla and I'm like really like with
the tortilla you're exaggerating and but
then you would hear it over and over and
over again and be like okay maybe this
sorry I'm getting a little emotional but
it's good yeah maybe this is possible
that
sorry
that what
it feels good to know that
you know we can do something that's
affecting people's lives in a positive
way and you know that we're doing it as
a family
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 stream us
right here on CBS News I'm Dana Jacobson
we'll see you next time for another
helping of the dish
[Music]